I go all the way back to the original
Super Mario Brothers which was the best
because it was so easy they would just
aim you in One Direction and this is
your whole video game right here
if you ran too far this way you can't
even go back that way get your fat ass
to the castle
the premise of Super Mario Brothers a
king's daughter gets kidnapped by a
giant dragon
and he sends Two Italian plumbers to go
rescue
the king got all his hands together and
he's like all right we need to get my
little girl back I do not want to spend
a lot of money ideas
they're like well Navy Seals that's
expensive Marines are pretty costly one
guy races saying hey you remember those
two guys that fixed the toilet last week
yeah the one found the upper decker we
had no idea what that smell was